uh good evening my name is jack bennett
and behalf of all our staff welcome to
politics and prose before we begin this
evening i just want to say some few
notes first we ask you to science your
cell phones we record our events for
posterity and tonight c-span is here uh
so you don't want to be that person
whose phone rings in the middle of the
talk and two days later on c-span um
what we do want heard in the recording
are your questions during the q a
portion of the program so please do ask
your questions into the microphone to
the left
when the time comes the signing will
begin just afterwards at the table
beside me with the line stretching
towards the front of the store books are
available for purchase at the registers
after the event
um and one last note of store business
before uh before we begin for those
interested politics and pros will be
offering a class on paulo callow's new
novel hippie on december 4th
today's guest is the writer timothy
denevey whose new book a portrait of a
decade in the life of hunter s thompson
freak kingdom just came out today
adopting thompson's gonzo style on freak
kingdom devi creates a necessarily
fast-paced narrative of the most
significant decade of thompson's life
dynevy resuscitates an important and
unfor unfortunately overlooked aspect of
thompson's political thought his true
commitment to lowercase are republican
virtues and ultimately to the dream of
america rather than the american dream
please help me welcome timothy davey to
politics and prose
[Applause]
hi everyone
thank you very much for coming out uh
thank you jack for that introduction and
to politics and prose and to
c-span for being here um i'm very
excited to be able to read uh
here tonight for the release of the book
and to see so many good friends uh among
the uh among the crowd um i'm just gonna
read for about 20 minutes one of the few
things i tell my students they should
ever remember from my creative writing
classes is always to read for less time
than you're allotted and if that's all
you remember from your mfa
you'll be fine things will work out
it's good advice
um so this book as yak said is about um
hunter s thompson's political uh our
evolution as a political journalist and
activist in the years spanning jfk's
assassination to nixon's resignation
it's about his perception of power of
institutional injustice and the
fantastic possibilities
and deeply ingrained flaws of the
american system of government
and tonight i'm just going to read two
short
sections as i said about 20 minutes
total
i'm going to read about the chicago
democratic national convention in 1968
thompson went out to
write about it he had gotten a
press pass after the success of his
first book and so he was on hand for
much of the violence that would erupt
throughout the convention and the scene
i'm going to read from tonight is when
on
wednesday night at the convention
there's a police riot in front of the
hilton hotel where many of the
dignitaries within the democratic party
are staying and where
many journalists and other uh democratic
delegates are standing out front of as
the police arrive and he's uh there
among them earlier in the day he'd been
billy clubbed in the stomach by police
at grant park when he had showed them
his press pass and the police officer
said that's not a press pass he said
what the hell do you think it is and
they just rammed their rod right into
his stomach and
popped him over so now in this scene
he's ready
for the
sort of experience that he's just had
and he has his motorcycle helmet with
him in case
the violence
erupts again which is it's um it's about
to and so after that i'm going to read a
passage um that's about uh a year later
in 1969 nixon's inauguration um and how
thompson flew out from denver um flew
out from woody creek to cover nixon's
inauguration
on the evening of wednesday august 28
1968
day three of the democratic national
convention in chicago hunter s thompson
a 30 year old journalist working on his
second book was standing at the corner
of michigan in balboa a motorcycle
helmet stowed in a large blue kit
at his shoulder
around him seven thousand protesters had
pinned themselves into the four-way
intersection onto which the lake few
suites of both the sheridan blackstone
and the conrad hilton hotels looked down
from across the city evening was coming
on a late summer twilight arid and clear
the skyline throwing its great tusks of
shadow toward the lake
thompson had taken up a position against
the windows of the hilton's ground level
restaurant the haymarket inn
where from behind a row of yellow police
barricades he and other journalists
stood alongside a number of democratic
staffers and delegates who'd come down
from their rooms with their spouses to
see what was going on
just before 8 pm deputy superintendent
james rockford the on-site commander in
charge of convention security received
word that additional reinforcements had
begun to arrive
along with the contingent of paddy
wagons to transport prisoners
and to the officers gathered around and
off the perimeter he gave the order
clear the intersection
the shut the chicago police approached
from both ends of michigan and balboa in
tight military formation then they broke
into a full run charging into the crowd
for the most part they were young men
from irish and polish and german and
italian families
before the assault they'd taken off
their badges and nameplates
they knew
that the order
to attack had been delayed for nearly
half an hour deliberated upon
and once the word came down through the
chain of command arriving like a small
sum of money or an equally modest fine
there could be no doubt that it
represented the official position of
chicago's highest civilian authorities
a new round of tear gas follies shrouded
the intersection in the burning fog you
could hear clubs striking bone panicked
footsteps and the screams their
orchestral pain a breeze came up from
the lake it was night a new wave of cops
arrived together they chanted kill kill
kill and incantation as they approached
the intersection the protesters tried to
flee hey a young man with a mustache
said god damn a cop had doubled him over
with the club to the gut and was tossing
him into one of the paddy wagons
at that moment a television cameraman
was filming these wagons and now this
cop turned to attack him too a doctor in
a white coat and a red cross armband ran
to help and was knocked to the ground by
pairs of police who kept beating him as
he tried to call away crawl away
there were plain clothes cops
white shirted cops some had antennas at
their backs to relay radio instructions
others wore long black jackets with
chevrons at the shoulders a few were on
three wheeled motorcycles one of whom
could be heard as he ran people over
shouting wahoo
for 15 unbelievable minutes the battle
of michigan avenue raged on the entire
time hunter s thompson was standing
behind the yellow barricades with his
back to the hilton ground floor
restaurant watching it all up close
he and the other journalists were still
surrounded by older party officials and
their wives and from the start it had
been the safest spot initially there'd
even been chants of the whole world is
watching but now they were silent the
cops taking control were preparing a new
assault
on michigan avenue from both the north
and the south two fresh rows of police
were advancing they came together at the
hilton a classic pinster formation and
the streets remaining protesters perhaps
500 suddenly had nowhere to go the cops
kept pressing them back in the direction
of the hotel as floor level restaurant
the exact spot where thompson and the
others were standing
now the officers charged they sprayed
mace from handheld cans and came in fast
behind the wet fogging bursts the
protesters surged back over the
barricade thompson was forced against
the hilton stay together some of them
were shouting a few tried to break
through the line in groups but they were
quickly separated and beaten the cordon
was complete half a thousand people were
pinned against the plate glass windows
of the conrad hilton hotel the police
gathered again and blitzed their final
assault
thompson reached frantically for the
motorcycle helmet in his bag he slipped
it on just as the cops got to him bodies
at his back and feet and then the
overhand blow the billy club coming down
on the motorcycle helmet a plastic and
leather dome that would have amplified
into his ears the deafening bang at the
same time it had protected his skull and
brain which meant that unlike the other
concussed men and women lying around him
he could still register with all his
faculties intact the unmistakable
message the civic authorities were using
indiscriminate violence to silence their
legitimate political opposition and
journalistic observers
thompson knew immediately that if they
were willing to do this if on national
television the rights inherent to the
constitution of the united states could
be completely and unequivocally
discarded then they could do anything
from behind he heard a new crash
now the crowd was being forced through
the haymarket's plate glass window which
loudly shattered
men and women tumbled helplessly down
into the restaurant the police followed
them in leaping clubs drawn thompson was
a few feet away around him the cops
shoved past what was happening to the
people who only minutes before were
standing next to him were they down
there now on the ruthless grass strewn
floor of the haymarket
suddenly he was sure he was about to be
hit by a hail of bullets fired from
above from the rooftop the shot
exploding in his chest before he even
heard its report there was nothing he
could do
i've never been caught in an earthquake
he'd say about this moment
but i'm sure the feeling would be just
about the same total panic and disbelief
with no escape
something was coming that he couldn't
see speeding toward him from the menace
of the night at that instant pinned
against the shattered wall of the
haymarket he was overcome with the
terror and paralysis and regret of what
it means to be hit and then as if in a
nightmare go down
it was the sort of fear bobby kennedy
had been made to feel two months earlier
during those waning moments on the
ambassador hotel's concrete floor when
he could still ask if everyone else was
okay aware that his life was leaving him
but helpless to do anything but watch it
go we're talking about the saddest
moment of all the one in which you
finally realize you're beyond everyone
else's reach
inside the hilton a protester with a
severed neck artery was slumped against
the wall another his legs paralyzed
crawled on his elbows the cops beat them
anyway beating the diners who'd been
sitting in the haymarket too then they
moved on to the lobby clear the floor
one of them shouted by now they didn't
care about arresting people the
intersection was secure
just then hunter s thompson saw an
opening
through the remaining crowd of police
and wounded protesters he sprinted to
the blackstone about 60 feet away where
the cops near the entrance clubbed him
back i live here god damn it he screamed
i'm paying 50 a day
he was shoved into the door he pulled
out his room key and waved it overhead
until finally someone let him push
through into the lobby
in his room he locked and changed his
door
his eyes burned his clothes stanked with
chemicals his gut ached but he was
unharmed he wet a cloth and held it
carefully to his face to soak out the
tear gas
then he sat on the bed his legs crossed
his entire body was shaking he couldn't
write none of it made sense the whole
week the police had known he was a
member of the press that the men and
women they'd forced through the
haymarket window were political
officials that a number of the
non-violent young protesters worked as
campaign staffers for democratic
candidates then that was the horrific
point
years later looking back on this moment
he'd write
these bastards knew my position and they
wanted to beat me anyway they were
powerful enough to break anybody who
even thought about getting in their way
what i learned in chicago was that the
police arm of the united states
government was capable of hiring
vengeful thugs to break the very rules
we all thought we were operating under
the violence he just witnessed was
clearly state-sanctioned political and
it had originated within the core
electoral process of the democratic
system the primaries it now threatened
in this sense we were its authors and
performers and intended audience all
along this violence had been with us
was us
a song for america we'd been singing
from the start
it was just after 9 p.m
at the stockyards amphitheater the
official balloting for the presidential
nomination was about to begin
thompson still had his press pass it had
been around his neck the entire time and
he planned to put it to use now for
something other than an invitation to a
beating
and so
later that night thompson goes to the
democratic national convention and sees
muskie get nominated and is in the press
apron and is screaming um at the
georgia delegation the alabama
delegation um that they should nominate
martin borman who's the famous nazi
because they're trying to nominate bull
connor who's the famous police chief um
and eventually daley's thugs kicked him
out um but this was right about the time
when abribikoff was on stage and said
if we didn't have these gestapo tactics
going on in the streets of chicago we
would be able to he was ripped off was
referring to
mayor daley's
police riot that had just happened and
mayor daley said something we can't
repeat here but basically um said f you
you know like
you i mean we can swear right can we
swear he said [ __ ] you you know and he
said and he slurred him and it it was
and daley you know said you you jew
bastard [ __ ] you to abribikoff
abercroft's the um senator of
connecticut and rivikov said how hard it
is
how hard it is to accept the truth and
daley could hear him saying that so
thompson wrote ribakoff a letter after
that saying how impressed he was with uh
river cough being the only one who could
stand up to daily in that moment and at
that instant on the floor um
so
a little bit of context now i'll read
one more small scene this is from
nixon's inauguration and one thing i'll
say about this is that um thompson was
really attuned to how much the protest
movement began to change after chicago
where there may have been some writing
by the
protesters but it was a non-violent
protest and that non-violence did not
work in the way non-violence had earlier
and so thompson left questioning how can
you protest against injustice and still
make sure that the people who are
perpetrating this injustice and part of
it listen to what you have to say and
change and he began to think that the
people that are now in charge aren't
capable of doing that and aren't capable
of listening and how is that degrading
everything that's going on around it and
so um
you know that police riot that i just
read basically got nixon elected when um
pat buchanan was watching that event
with norman mailer and drinking on the
15th floor of the um hilton which is in
the book but which i cut off from that
mailer um
turned to buchanan buchanan said that he
knew right then that nixon who buchanan
worked for had won the election as soon
as that a riot happened because how
could hubert humphrey who was the
nominee
ever show that he could control the
country or be in charge of the country
when his own party had just destroyed
itself in chicago and so
um the only other thing you need to know
here i cut out a large part of this that
i'm about to read where if you've seen
the vietnam war documentary and read
farrell's excellent book on nixon nixon
basically committed nixon basically
nixon committed treason right before he
was elected president he interfered with
the vietnam war peace discussions by
contacting south vietnam and telling
them that he would get them a better
deal if they stayed out of the peace
negotiations at that moment and johnson
knew it johnson called him and nixon's
like i never i would never do that he's
like you did that we both know you did
it like you committed treason but
johnson didn't have any um cachet with
the american public anymore because he'd
been lying to them about the war so he
chose not to call nixon out on that so
as soon as nixon took office he was
deeply deeply compromised
and he had been the shapeshifter who had
been able to attain
whatever he thought the electric wanted
to become
president but now he'd kind of been
locked into this form of injustice
because he'd done
something so absurdly terrible commit
trees and that part of the dirty tricks
and part of the aspects of watergate
that you'd see later trying to break
into the brookings institution and
bombing the vault the planning of that
was to make sure that the story of his
treason never came out so i've cut out
that and this is just thompson going to
the inauguration and being horrified um
and this will be our final section that
we read and then we'll do um some
questions
on monday january 20th 1969 beneath the
low atlantic sky the color of what
concrete richard millhouse nixon
descended the steps at the capitals east
portico and repeated back the oath
administered to him by chief justice
earl warren taking office as the 37th
president of the united states
the greatest i'm gonna do a very bad
nixon voice the greatest honor history
can bestow is the title of peacemaker he
proclaimed in his address when we listen
to the better angels of our nature we
finally celebrate the simpler things the
basic things such as goodness decency
love kindness
hunter thompson made the trip east from
colorado to cover the inauguration for
the boston globes weekend magazine
the peace we seek is not victory over
any other people but the peace that
comes with healing in its wings nixon
said
as our eyes catch the dimness of the
first rays of the dawn let us not curse
the remaining dark let us gather the
light
immediately thompson recognized the
source of the overwrought rhetoric ray
price the administration's chief
speechwriter who'd helped spearhead
during the campaign the rebranding
effort that had sought to repackage
nixon as a patriotic stabilizing unifier
america so desperately needed
not that such a feat would have been
possible without this specific
candidate's unique mutability by this
point thompson had been writing about
nixon for nearly a decade and from the
start thompson had understood exactly
what it was that made this particular
politician so dangerous an innate and
sinister talent for deception that the
american electorate when presented over
and over again with its unabashed used
car salesman tenor somehow kept
mistaking for an entirely different
trait
ambition
and now in victory richard nixon
improved that he could become anything
including against all odds the
unquestioned leader of the free world
for its part nixon said at the end of
his address government will listen we
will strive to listen in new ways and
then he got into his enormous
bulletproof lincoln limousine and kicked
off the day's inaugural parade which in
his route from the capitol to the white
house would take him within a literal
stone's throw of the thousands of
protesters who line the city's winter
streets thompson thanks to his press
credentials
was able to stick out a prime spot at
the end of the parade route the corner
of pennsylvania and 15th street across
from the large stand of bleachers the
intersection where the president's
vanguard would make its penultimate turn
before passing into the vast security
cordon of the white house
it was early afternoon
the wind had come down from the
northeast freezing and brittle knocking
at everyone's hats and handbells and
high-collared coats nixon's motorcade
advanced directly into its teeth up the
city's long angled corridor pennsylvania
avenue a diagonal that connected one
seat of american power to another the
procession was led by a wedge of 30
police motorcycles secret service agents
trotted alongside
the protesters had posted up along the
parade route at three main locations
throughout the weekend they'd been
gathering for what was being called the
counter inaugural a multi-day event
organized by the same activists from the
1968 democratic national convention in
chicago including david dilliger and
jerry rubin who together were facing
five-year prison sentences in illinois
on trumped-up conspiracy to riot charges
after chicago the general mood of the
anti-war movement had soured
violence and confrontation are the
themes now thompson would write in his
globe feature
vicious dissidence is the style
as the motorcade approached the
intersection of 12th in pennsylvania the
site of the old post office and the
clock tower
the first small group was waiting they
were flanked front and back by navy
jacketed dc police and national
guardsmen as well as an additional
unarmed contingent from the army's 82nd
airborne division
not that it mattered as soon as the
limousine appeared they unleashed a
dense hail of rocks and sticks
members of the secret service walking
alongside struggled to bat down the
projectiles someone lofted a loft
ball-sized wad of tin foil that in its
precipitous arc appeared to be falling
directly toward the vehicle carrying mr
and mrs nixon which accelerated jolting
into occupants and forcing the agents
onto the street in an accompanying run
the next set of protesters the largest
had gathered at 14th street near the
national theater on the north side of
pennsylvania parade route's widest spot
here more than a thousand young men and
women chanted slogans at the motorcade
four more years of death
ho ho ho chi minh nlf is gonna win
two four six eight organized to smash
the state one two three four we don't
want your [ __ ] war
from the crowd came a new barrage a
paint-filled christmas ornament
shattered against the pavement a smoking
can was tossed just ahead of the
presidential limousine rolling
underneath national guardsmen and dc
police surged against the crowd reaching
for the assailants but the protesters
grabbed and beat anyone from law
enforcement
unlucky enough to venture too far into
their midst one cop after charging into
the crowd had been nearly stripped naked
and as a result the hail kept coming
down they threw stones bottles cans
firecrackers and smoke bombs they threw
pennies and rocks they threw table forks
at a spoon they threw tomatoes they
threw manure they lit on fire the
miniature american flags that the boy
scouts had been passing out and threw
them as hard as they could in the
general direction of the new president
it was 2 45 p.m hunter thompson was
still in his spot at pennsylvania and
15th street across the avenue in the
white plank beach bleachers
where the counter-inaugural leaders had
legitimately purchased 200 tickets
protesters were holding up signs with
messages like stop the war against black
america and nixon is the one the number
one war criminal they waved vietcong
banners they passed around a blotchy
dark sack they kept calling the black
flag of anarchy
someone threw a half gallon jug of wine
standing alongside thompson a newscaster
from nbc announced under the microphone
here comes the president
from around the corner the limousine
appeared a sort of huge hollowed-out
cannibal on wheels thompson would write
a very nasty looking armored car
there was a stench of bedrock finality
to it
it had been a year of assassinations and
police riots and defeats that had led
for hunter thompson
to the most unthinkable outcome of all
richard nixon's victory march to the
white house lawn
the whole concept of peaceful protests
died at the democratic national
convention thompson wrote that night for
his boston globe piece
up until chicago there had been the
assumption however far-fetched that the
politicians running the country were
capable of perceiving a mass
demonstration on something like the war
in vietnam within the context of
america's general political reality that
they were listening were willing to play
by the same set of guidelines the
republic had agreed upon two centuries
earlier even if they vehemently
disagreed with what they heard
the 1960s were full of examples of good
powerful men changing their minds on
heavy issues thompson would write years
later the pinnacle of this being lyndon
johnson's shocking decision to recognize
his failure in vietnam and preemptively
forego a second term
which is why the current reality for
thompson felt so devastating with agnew
and nixon and mitchell coming into power
he'd explain there was simply no point
in yelling at the [ __ ]
they were born deaf and stupid
he'd realized that it no longer mattered
how effectively you conducted a
demonstration the people you were hoping
to reach were incapable of hearing what
you had to say
the presidential limousine continued
past thompson he watched it turn from
15th street to the white house and then
disappear behind a wall of black
leafless trees the temperature was
dropping
the sky thickened and dimmed now the
protesters were fighting among
themselves police rode by on horseback
the wind lifted and let fall the
parade's long ribbon of debris overhead
an enormous helicopter beat the air the
city smelled the way it always does in
winter like dust and freezing rain and
shallow stagnant water thompson zipped
up a ski jacket and walked south toward
the mall around him the white sand
statues and memorials revealed
themselves haphazardly like relics their
individual meaning suddenly subsumed
beneath the thing the city had become
mr nixon city
a monument to the office he'd finally
won to him
[Applause]
thank you
everyone um well this is awkward there's
one more page uh
i just like it when people clap a lot
i'm really terrible um
i think i'll always read these last two
paragraphs that will open up the
questions i'm very vain
sit down stand up sit down i'm the worst
shout out to uh our nova knights who are
my baseball team who's here that should
break the tension right now
federal league champions that's are we
looser now or at least okay let's see
and so the last two paragraphs for
thompson
from the mall hunter has thomas you
could see arlington cemetery it's vast
hillside landscaped evenly with even
more graves than he could count that was
part of the monument too the worst part
across the gray river bobby kennedy lay
closed in a coffin only a few feet off
from that of his older brother both of
them forced now to adorn in death in
silence the sinister spectacle of the
president of the present
the only thing necessary for the triumph
of evil is for good men to do nothing
bobby kennedy had said just before he
was assassinated
a quote his brother had attributed to
edmund burke thompson would never forget
hearing this line he'd hold it dear for
the rest of his life we want a day as
haunting as this one such wisdom could
be heard to mean something different
it's only after the very best of us are
driven into silence that the most
destructive characteristics in our
nature find the means to flourish
and suddenly hunter thompson felt
disgusted and disillusioned and at a
loss
overhead the sky was about to break he
walked back to his hotel in the wind
what a fantastic monument he'd later
write to all the best instincts of the
human race this country might have been
if we could have kept it out of the
hands of greedy little hustlers
like richard nixon
yeah
that went well it went well
[Applause]
um
not awkward go ahead and so now we'll do
questions anybody has any questions
please please let me know hi hi
um i lived through all of this i
graduated from college in 1969.
um talk a little more about hunter
thompson
i wasn't really aware of him then
um even though
when i got to law school
uh in 1969 there was the moratorium
and the mobilization and all of that
what was his background how is he
different than you know the
the more familiar
what i know about hunter thompson is
mostly from dunesbury
um
well underdogs cases was fascinating to
me because he um started on a normal
journalistic route in the
1960s he was a correspondent throughout
south america for the national observer
and he was a stringer writing articles
that he'd send back up to new york and
would be published um
short little articles that were not
nearly voiced in the same way we'd later
see his work take on
and these articles often dealt with
really extreme issues like the death of
democracy in peru or coos or
there's one of a british like
foreign legion or a british ambassador
hitting golf balls from his patio down
into the poor slums um beneath and
thompson just dramatizes that and the
guy's just asking for more gin and
tonics and you know so he he was very
attuned to injustice um then and growing
up in louisville he had had friends when
he was 18 who with him were accused of a
robbery that he didn't commit and they
were able to get off because their
fathers were really wealthy
louisvillians and
he went to jail for 30 days so then he
joined the air force afterward and he
was in the air force and was honorably
discharged after that that was in the
late 50s or the mid to late 50s and so
in the early 60s he was a journalist who
then um
ended up going west because he thought
that the cultural movement would
originate there and so he was present
for the free speech movement in the
early 1960s which morphed into the
moratorium and he was present
when the um
12 000 first person march tried to break
through um oakland from berkeley to
march towards the terminal and the
hell's angels burst through and began to
beat the protesters and the police had
to beat the hell's angels um and he was
at the center of all of that while he
was writing his angels
angels is about
a really like angry motorcycle gang and
violent motorcycle game but it's also
about the west in the mid-1960s and it's
about
the limitations and the um promises of
the counterculture and so he was very in
tune with that and stylistically he was
always pushing um to move beyond the
standard journalistic
attempt at objectivity and so when the
new journalistic wave of writing came
about he was a fan of norman mailer he'd
read john didion's work he understood
that there was more space um through
subjectivity dramatization um essayistic
comment to um
write about america and write about its
political um
the political experience of america at
the time and so to finish up with that
question one thing that he did really
well is
there's a review of his 1972 um campaign
book in the new york times and it
compares him to norman mailer and to
theodore white theodor white's the guy
who wrote the making of the president
and would follow um it's like woodward
basically that kind of um work and would
kind of knew everybody was chummy with
everybody then there's mailer who would
come in and mail us problematic and
mailer would come in for
a week or two and write these like songs
for america these really complex odes to
what our tradition and nation are
thompson was in the middle he was
writing about something larger than what
was happening but he was also spending
the time over nine months to be a beat
reporter on the campaign trail and so
that dual experience of spending every
day waking up with the candidate with
the other journalists and also of
striving to articulate something bigger
than an article of information
has given him in my
opinion
a beautiful place when it comes to
writing about
the press american democracy and how the
promises and the limitations play out
repeatedly and in worse ways when we see
abuses of power at the national level
and then after
after
1972
or 1968
what happened to it well in 68 after he
went home and he cried for two weeks and
like he after he was hit in the head
he's like i cried for two weeks like i
didn't leave my room um i mean it was
terrifying to see that so he got
involved in local politics and with um
james salter the fiction writer he ran a
mayoral campaign in aspen
and then he also ran for sheriff in
aspen and it was after he ran for
sheriff on a really serious platform it
was beautiful he wanted to be like an
ombudsman not armed the sheriff because
there'd been no incidences emphasis
civil rights emphasized the environment
and he also was an nra member and you
know he also
was an individualist he was very liberal
but he was also
more complex than i think he's made out
to be so long story short
he was re-energized by that run for
sheriff and realizing that you can work
within the democratic system instead of
having to tear it down and that was his
experience somebody like oscar zetacosta
his good friend who's um in the book a
lot was a civil rights attorney in los
angeles it was a different situation the
police were killing him and his friends
and he didn't have the same
position society that thompson did and
so oscar was more revolutionary and
rightly so um and so then thompson after
that got in touch with rolling stone and
went back out on the campaign trail and
went to national politics again
does that make sense you're welcome
officer
i'm wondering what you think of the sort
of pop culture portrayal of thompson the
way that we know him as sort of a kooky
eccentric
unstable genius
um thank you carrie a brilliant writer
gary fullen
you know i think that
we need to be careful that we don't
become caricatures of ourselves and
that's something that happened to
thompson and so this book tries to focus
on
who he was before that because i think
there's some really negative aspects of
that character there's there's things
that don't it's not just that they don't
hold up well they were exaggerations of
some of his worst traits um
and so
one thing doug brinkley says his um the
presidential historian and the um person
in charge of his literary state is that
for this decade thompson
was
taking dexadrine
to which is a stimulant to work and that
later he would take drugs to escape work
but during this decade he was so
overwhelmed and he was so intent on
trying to report on the american
condition um that he he was much busier
than he ever dramatized himself being on
the page and so the dramatized version
we now get whether it's in a um kind of
surrealist film you know or somebody
dressed up at halloween as him um that
kind of masculine um
careless perspective
um that was part of a persona that he
had created on the page and eventually
became trapped in i i would argue later
in his life um
in his own experience but that when he
was creating that persona on the page
that was the writer in the moment at the
typewriter trying to show himself as
acting humorously in the past and trying
to show the distance between the past
self even if it were two days earlier
three days earlier and the present self
um he dramatizes bewilderment very well
he traumatizes just being lost being
confused and that's always the past him
um and so you know the last line of the
book is um
you know that um
the worst thing of all is um
the eulogy that you never get to write
which is for yourself and you know
basically that's the summary of it but
you have to be careful that the
narrative you create will be out of your
hands or that you'll become a caricature
of it and so i find that version to be
especially today not as
compelling as the um
serious artist and journalist i mean as
carrie knows i'm not i don't have a
journalistic background i've been in
creative writing classes since i was 18
and i've done a lot of journalism but
thompson was a serious working
professional journalist who understood
everything he was doing and what rules
he was breaking when he went to break
them he began as a serious journalist
writing the way
a journalist would write a story about a
baseball game or a story about a
political rally and then chose to
deviate from that formally and i think
it's difficult now because people start
at that deviation they start at a
experimental informal place and we got
to remember that he spent a lot of years
sending those articles back to new york
and having them cut in half you know and
just trying to get money out of them
and having
what he thought was the most important
aspects of them thrown aside you know
thank you carrie
ryan
ask questions don't be shy we're all
going to play ping pong later it'll be
lovely
hi tim doubles hi ryan um could you talk
about all the research you did in the
kind of process of research and how that
um
how you took that into writing um i know
it was like a many years that went into
this yeah it nearly killed me yes um
it's a very good question um ryan's
another excellent um writer from george
mason
i am
i wanted this book to be dramatized and
feel like a novel but i wanted
everything in it to be true and i wanted
everything in it to be accounted for so
the book is about 250 pages of narrative
which is oh i would
want any reader to read but then it has
another 100 pages or you know 50 000
words of notes and those notes account
for every sight smell sound
bang thought quote
that happens and they were also a space
to
think essayistically
to have me on the page you know and so
if i say that san francisco smelled like
um near the bay machine oil you know
where the scene is taking place i'll say
that i've you know grew up going to this
um spot of san francisco i know the spot
of san francisco and i know that it's
unchanged since then so i want the
reader to see where i started with the
information how i rendered it into
narrative because as soon as we make a
narrative we're
changing reality as soon as we apply or
put into the details of the world
put them into a narrative we are
moving away from what objectively
happened and that being said
i wanted the reader to know
what four versions of the story i was
looking at why i thought the one that i
chose to tell was true and so all of the
notes are filled with
are filled with where the information
came from and then building off of that
are filled with me thinking
in a sense essentially with you the
reader about why these choices would be
made and then as a final note i you
can't
anytime you write about another writer
or another figure you can't sound like
them in your prose you know it wouldn't
it would never ever work and so under
thompson's prose i enjoy but it can be
like a magnet and i wanted to make sure
that none of my sentences
ever sounded like his writing and so i
was reading certain writers at the time
that were magnet in the other direction
like james salter or like joan didion
and so i will put if i have like an
image in the
text where the long tusks of shadow
thrown out across the water i'll have
the line from the bhakov where
in signs importance he the the um signs
and symbols the grandfather takes the
teeth out of his mouth and there's long
tusks of saliva connecting the teeth to
his mouth so i'll have that full passage
because i guess in non-fiction with um
like fair usage you can just use all you
want like you can use paragraphs and
paragraphs of beautiful writing and put
it in the back which is what i did so if
you look at the notes which aren't part
of the index there's just tons of like
paragraphs of michael and doj and joan
didion and nabakov and um
and and other writers and um
yeah ryan was in class when i would kind
of walk bleary-eyed in and out um as if
in a fog because i was getting maybe
four hours of sleep and doing you know
14 hours of research for six hours of
writing and um
it was not something i will do again but
it was uh it was worth it i guess
uh why not
my family are the ones who were the best
about that i mean part of this is i
wrote this book at night um i the
deadline was approaching so rapidly that
for about three months i
would get up at 4 or 5 p.m
stay up all night until about 10 am and
then sleep during the day so there was
no email no news um no errands to run
any of that so i was able to spend time
with my family in the morning and
evening but i was pretty much gone from
the world and gone from the media of the
world which to me was
pretty much the only way to live in this
past i was writing about and get after
it hi stuart how are you tim how are you
thanks very much
were you inspired to write this by the
because you saw the relevance of hunter
s thompson for a current political
situation
did you did you start before and then
changed the direction of the book when
you saw what was happening
on a political
scale i mean i think
all of us whatever side of the
aisle that we're on whatever our
political police like after
2016 and everything that's happened
since it's hard to see america in the
same way no matter where we start from
it's hard to see the people across the
aisle in the same way
and i had been trying to write about
justice um and thompson and how hunter
thompson had gone in 1971 to east los
angeles he was writing about how um
members of the chicano rights movement
were being murdered and how by police
and how reuben salazar this
brilliant newscaster from los angeles
was killed during a police riot like
chicago
and
after then to try to get a sense of what
thompson's experiences were after i went
to the 19 i'm sorry to the 2016 national
conventions in
cleveland and philadelphia
and after um
on election night being at the trump
hotel at 9 pm where i get a text from
brett my wife that shows the image on
the new york times
probability a little uh
measurement going from 90 hillary to 10
hillary and i'm watching on tv as
everybody who's come there to celebrate
trump just erupts into an incredible and
cacophonous um
cheer because it's 9 p.m and all of the
states are going
for trump and against hillary
and then looking back at moments like
the
kennedy assassination and how um
thompson was affected by that and
looking back at the 1964 democratic
republican national convention where
barry goldwater said um
extremism and defense of liberty is no
vice and thompson was on the floor he
bribed a guard to get down there so
didn't mailer and thompson looks around
and everybody's banging their chairs and
screaming and he feels this form of
political violence he feels that at any
moment
this can become not political enthusiasm
but political violence um so yes to
answer your questions it's impossible to
not look back at all those events and
see them through the lens of the present
which i think again
storytelling is always about the present
you know that's the that's the prism
that we put on we're never going to be
objective and so if it's a version of
hunter thompson you're looking to write
that version is going to be pinned to
what's happened now and i i do believe
that what he has to say about
the american republican injustice and
unjust leaders and
extremism on both sides
is as relevant now as ever
thanks
hi thanks for your presentations i have
two questions you can only answer one of
them and choose which one you want to
answer
the first one is
which of his books was your favorite and
why
and the second one is do you see sort of
him as a continuation of the beat
generation those writers
and so in what context so good both
great or just choose which one you want
well no i i i really love strange
rumblings in azelan which i make in my
class read tomorrow i think there's some
people here but um it's a 20 000 word
narrative account um where he goes to
east los angeles and reports on abuse um
within the lapd and he's being attacked
or he's
disliked by members of the brown beret
movement and for good cause because he's
an interloper you know who's friends
with oscar costa is part of the movement
but they don't know if they can trust
him like they're right to be suspicious
and the cops are he you know they
they're they don't want him asking
questions about how they killed a
journalist and so he is as a character
in that
he plays sort of
a back seat role to the drama that's
going on and i think that's a nice place
for part of his more dramatized
interactions and i also love the
campaign trail 72 is my uh it's my very
favorite um
and the second question
you know a whole generation that
thompson was a part of were stuck in
between the beats and the kind of hippie
generation and this is ken casey's um on
the bus crew and this is um neil cassidy
who was a a member of the beats so neil
cassidy's in this book um and so so is
ken kisi who are both friends with
thompson and we're close to thompson and
i think he understood
their aesthetics
and also the um promises and limitations
of their approaches and they they deeply
affected his disillusionment
with the
anti-war movement and disillusionment
with consciousness expansion is
something that's just going to make
everything better i think thompson
believed like wisdom is how you get
better living and learning is how you
improve your perspective you can't take
lsd and suddenly you'll see through time
and space and everybody will get along i
mean i you know that's thompson's
perspective is that you earn wisdom um
and so his relationships with the beats
and in the honda in san francisco on the
hate
were instrumental in his prose style and
in his perspective
welcome
sports questions no thompson's first
football game 1965 frankel olfield
yeah he was an afl fan hey tim i'm just
curious what lessons you took out of
writing this book
in terms of the craft of writing yeah um
thank you eric's another brilliant
writer at george mason that's that's an
excellent question i
that writing uh all right i'll quote
hunter thompson this is an inappropriate
uh comment but
no i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna
quote thompson's writing is never fun
writing is never fun it's basically
thompson's comment um and at best you
don't realize you're doing it um and so
you know eric
that's a good question it's like money
in the bank that those those eight hours
those six hours those 10 hours you look
back things are accruing pages are
accruing um and also that writing is not
as solitary um
an act as we tend to think it's a
collaborative art form my editor was
fantastic my poor editor i was so close
to my deadline it was just like editing
my chapters before the other chapters
were done and going through and giving
me fantastic edits like stay in the past
tense you don't need to go into the
present tense here like let's maybe
write chronologically that's a good idea
do it you know he's like do whatever you
want like dramatize like move around
like in the chicago scene i go up into
the hilton and i go into the
perspectives of all the um
politicians that are watching it and
he's like yeah that's fine he's like do
whatever you want in the notes you know
he's like sure a say like wander around
in those that's fine with me so he was
um very very helpful and
very um i i don't think without that i
could have
got it done and put the same amount of
pressure on it that i had hoped to and
so that idea of collaboration and that
idea also of perseverance and money in
the bank are
are key um and
yeah maybe next time i'm not gonna
research so heavily in my uh in my uh
maybe we'll do another sort of sort of
project that doesn't do that um so good
thank you eric
tim how are you thanks for being here
good to see you i had some questions
about can you tell us a little bit about
his time at espn
uh as well as his essay on 911 well i
mean that's good for me thompson was
i'll answer that two ways that's next
question
for me thomas almost problematic later
on in his life um
i think he his body and his mind
suffered from how hard he pushed himself
how much of an alcoholic he was earlier
in his life and so i have not researched
that
time in his life as specifically a great
book to read as juan thompson's stories
i tell myself which is a memoir one
thompson's hunter thompson's son about
growing up with hunter thompson and
covers that time period it starts with
it being very hard when they were young
and then it becomes
beautiful because they got close at the
end of hunter thompson's life and became
really dear friends but
to answer your question tim thompson
started as a sports writer when he
you know got the hell out of louisville
joined the air force um and was on i
think eglin air force base he basically
worked his way into the journalism
department there at the air force and he
just wrote sports articles and he was a
he was a great sports journalist so he
always understood he writes about it the
kind of meritriciousness of sports
writing where all you need is like a
thesaurus you know and the and like
describe a tackle in a different way but
he also he also
was was an understood sport in american
culture and how
football especially in the 60s and 70s
and nixon's relationship with football
um
was
sort of integral to understanding what
was going on the only time thompson ever
and many of you may know this the only
time thompson ever got to
spend time with nixon one on one was in
1968 in the new hampshire primary
where they're like come here he's like
what did i do what do you want and
they're like get in the back of the car
and he's like okay thompson does and
nixon's in the back of the car and they
have to drive for 30 minutes to the
nashua airport in new hampshire
and thompson not knowing what to ask and
knowing that nixon just gives the same
road answer to every question regarding
politics asks him about football
and nixon just opens up he's like oh the
guy from miami super bowl two the pump
fake like pats him on the back thompson
and basically thompson he'd write about
this many times in his life but he i
liked his writing about it closest to
the moment he wrote a pageant article
about it right then thompson says it was
the only time
in his life basically that he knew
richard nixon wasn't lying that's when
he talked about he knew he was sure
nixon wasn't lying when he talked about
super bowl too
and then he nearly blew up the plane
because he was smoking near it but it's
a long story
good
how are we doing on time other questions
hi haley good to see you
um so was there any
anything that you found in your research
whether that was about whether it's
about hunter s thompson or just the
political atmosphere of the 70s that
really surprised you
um
yeah that's a that's an outstanding
question
i was a lot of what i just read um
today from the police riot
was drawn from multiple sources of video
um
there was an investigation by um lbj
into it um that accrued an enormous
amount of um
of personal testimony but there's a book
uh chicago 68 um by farber that um
goes through all of those scenes that i
was describing and it doesn't dramatize
it in that way but it gives the sources
for all of them and i was shocked by the
level of violence in these cultural
moments that i had
known about historically i knew growing
up about that i knew about
that
inauguration i had no idea they were
throwing paint-filled christmas
ornaments at that that and let's watch
this video they have old stuck video you
see just the lob and the throw and you
see it roll under the car and there's
this incredibly tense moment of them
speeding up and them running and the
anger and i was i was deep i i was i
wasn't shocked but i i found it
terrifying and fascinating and
i think thompson was very good at
savaging the left as much as he savaged
the right and that was really important
it gave him credibility he was as hard
on lbj you know as he was on nixon um
and because he was it was about justice
and he was hard as hard on ed muskie and
hubert horatio humphrey you know as he
was on certain um
republican officials and
i i found that to be important and i
when i'd see moments like the nixon
inauguration and see how the left was
acting how the right was acting and see
how thompson had depicted that i'd get a
better sense and i don't know if today
we often
have a chance to witness writers
putting as much pressure on both sides
of the aisle and it's hard to do it
because injustice is different
officer
um to that point actually i'm curious
what kind how do you think conor s
thompson
would have fit into this contemporary
media landscape of twitter and
i think twitter would have been terrible
for him i mean
i think instead of writing or he would
have he would have been on twitter um
that's a really good question
i think that
he would have pushed back against
the cable news aspect of talking heads
and being a celebrity and having a
career throughout
articulating the most extreme point and
kind of that
celebrity culture of
looking like
a newscaster or looking like an expert
instead of actually being an expert
i think he would have pushed back
against the extremism that we're seeing
now where
we really believe in america that
rhetoric can be divorced from reality
and violence and obviously we know
that's not true we've always known that
but we've seen it so much recently
and i think he would have pushed back
against
the way that this specific
administration tries to um
manipulate the press and the way that
the press through no fault of their own
often gets stuck
and can and this is an extreme comment
become complicit in the lies and in the
terrible
aspects of the trump administration they
don't they're doing that but they don't
mean to but that's the [ __ ] of the
trump administration right now is that
their ability to use the press to um
lie to the american public and overwhelm
the press and that's why i think
michelle wolf's
white house correspondents michelle
wolf's committee and her white house
correspondents um talk where she made
everybody deeply uncomfortable by acting
basically like trump and calling trump a
racist what she did as marcia geston
wrote in the new yorker is call out the
press for thinking that they can have
access to these extremely powerful
figures who are deeply unjust and
hurting america and at the same time
write about them in a clear and um just
way you know and that that's not working
right now you have to give up access for
correctness you know you have to give
access for being just and right and i
think he would have been willing to give
up access and would not have been
dependent on access even as someone
who's following the campaign and would
have stayed true to his
um perspective of injustice i mean i
remember there's a lot of writers today
like masha gessen who are more essayists
or more
cultural critics but thompson was on the
campaign show every day you know he's
with the writers that were strictly
filing information about what had
happened and he saw the way nixon
manipulated reality by making all of the
writers watch a nixon speech on a closed
circuit television and not letting in
the writers anywhere near nixon and
basically allowed nixon to
get out to the american public the
version nixon wanted and it took so much
effort to go against that and thompson
did he had the space to do it so he'd
dramatize all the reporters having to go
into pens he dramatized nixon's terrible
um
public relations staff
ian rodzie ron ziegler he would put them
on the page and show how awful they were
but it takes so much effort to dramatize
the way
information is being given to you
instead of relaying the information and
then maybe having a comment on it you
know and it wears you down and it wears
journalists down and i i think it wore
him down um being on that campaign trail
and going through it but i think that's
what he would have fought to articulate
today
all right
one more question maybe
the title um good
there are three the title comes from
three quotes so
it was the most famous one which is from
fear and loathing
where thompson's at the um
he's been trying to get long story short
he's been trying to get oscar's data
costs to talk to him about ruben
salazar's murder but oscar's ada costa
is under surveillance from like naval
intelligence
and the fbi and the speci this was
actually a part of the lapd the special
operations for conspiracy it was the
actual like they named it the that was
the title of it was to undermine um
groups was they would infiltrate civil
rights groups have people within those
civil rights groups attack police so
that police could use deadly force
against members of the civil rights
groups and silence them so oscar akasa
is like we can't talk here man um we
need to get a convertible we need to go
to las vegas and that's where that all
stems from is that you can't be bugged
if you're in a convertible going to las
vegas so they go and basically oscar
acosta takes a plane home and leaves
thompson with a giant gun and a ton of
marijuana which is deeply illegal at
that time it's like 20 years in prison
and thompson has to drive it back to la
and thompson just begins to panic
and so he just wants to get back to los
angeles so badly and he describes being
back in los angeles as
safety obscurity to be on the hollywood
freeway to be just another freak in the
freak kingdom
you know to be anonymous again and not
in las vegas which was a very
conservative town um was as he says
sinatra's town spiro agnews town you
know richard nixon's kind of town um and
the second quote is from
if you're living on the campaign show 72
where
thompson's covering the muskie campaign
and ed muskey had been a democratic
politician who supported the vietnam war
and had um in 68 at the convention and
so thompson couldn't stand them he was
doing this whistle stop tour on a train
and thompson um meets at 3 a.m
this very large and very drunk man who
had known everybody thompson knew
in san francisco and la honda
his name was peter sheridan
so they go out drinking and sheridan's
like just out of jail on vagrancy
charges and it's like i just was going
to hitchhike down to miami tommy's like
you know
whatever man come with me take my press
pass and so this happens and thompson
puts his press pass in the elevator
sends the elevator down this guy gets it
and thompson's like they'll let me on i
write you know like they all know me and
they don't wake thompson up the musky
campaign the next day because they don't
like him and so thompson sleeps
musky the muskie campaign sheridan gets
on the train drinks 15 martinis runs up
and down it the whole trip and then when
muskie gives his big speech at the end
grabs his grabs muskie's leg as muskie's
giving the speech from underneath like
the train car while jerry rubin the
activist is screaming like why do you
support vietnam at muskie muskie just
begins to fall back and it's like scene
and thompson describes sheridan as
a true aristocrat in the freak kingdom
he knew him from the first time he saw
him and so finally there's those two but
where it really comes from is
in the sheriff's debate in 1968 i'm
sorry in the sheriff's debate 1970
thompson um
you know basically said it's the it's
the upper graph to this book and to
paraphrase it he said i'm not insulted
by the word freak you know to deviate
from um the norms in our society today
to fight back against an unjust
government is is what we're asked to do
and i find it an honor and a distinction
and that's where freak power came from
and so
those are the how's the origins well
thank you everyone for coming out so
much
[Applause]
ask me more questions if you have any
come play ping pong
one handed backhand
all right wraps pitch in the second game
[Music]
over the past